hey becca
are you working online yeah i'm working
online
tommy are you doing online school yeah
i'm online
nathan are you online yeah i'm gonna
hide
hey jacob are you online i'm online
why are we doing this at the beach
you guys want to go in and see the
rental house yeah
the front door is on like the third
story so
go ahead and check this out
this is like the fourth story this place
is huge
whoa we got the full moon in the ocean
right there
windy and cold look at the size of that
tv
nathan can't even reach the top of the
thing mom what about you
and there's a jacuzzi this is
more than enough house for us and uh my
parents who are
gonna join us later this week is that
cool jacob
well good morning you guys sleep well
yeah let's
check this out
it is a beautiful beautiful sunday so
we're gonna
we're gonna do online church right here
we're gonna take it easy and relax a
little bit
and uh then we got some fun things
planned for this week
this has been such a relaxing day
started off pretty gorgeous but it's
windy and a little bit of a storm coming
in
all right let's make some dinner hope
you guys are hungry
well the storm just knocked the power
out isn't that exciting
hey the power's back on
all right let's go cook some hamburgers
well good morning it is warm and cozy
inside and beautifully sunny
so i'm gonna make breakfast for
everybody and then i'm probably gonna
spend the rest of the day
editing looks like my parents are here
hi mom
[Music]
it's like beetle mania yeah oh
sharon this is fabulous i thought that
was brilliant
oh all right i want to do some off the
beach shark fishing
and uh we're going to need a kayak if
we're going to do that
all right that's it sign some paperwork
picked out my kayak and they're gonna
drop it off at the rental house
in the next hour or two so not bad at
all all right well the rental kayak
arrived
i've never seen this this is gonna be
exciting
when you're shark fishing long leaders
are nice because it lets the fish
chew on it so check this out
there we go that's my leader
whole mullet is bait right there
oh that was cold
okay
oh
[Music]
i don't know what i'm doing but luke is
out kayaking and this is like going
crazy
i think i should do something but i
don't know what so we're just gonna reel
and see what happens
i don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
back
there you go
oh my harm sore thanks mom for videoing
for me
oh he just got a nice hit on this one
yes
kind of yes
we got a ton of bites on this short rod
and it just
never quite hooked up properly but it
was acting like maybe a small
shark on there but it's getting time to
go home so let's reel in
all right go for it reel it in buddy
yep we got our bait oh we'll be out here
tomorrow
well it's wednesday morning and i'm
gonna go do a fishing charter
unfortunately it's just gonna be me
because it's gonna be a lot of casting
and sight casting the boys coin aren't
up to that yet but uh let's grab some
breakfast and
see if we can't catch some fish see you
guys in a little bit
we're here all right i think that's our
boat oh i'm ready to have a good time
all right man
all right guys i'm here with captain
crockett here on real obx
and uh we're gonna be targeting a lot of
different species uh maybe some redfish
uh maybe some different types of trout
uh kind of whatever
whatever's out there that's right all
right so we're cruising around these
flats and oyster beds and around these
marshes
he's up in the tower and he's gonna
hopefully be able to spot
the fish we're targeting so got eyes in
the sky here
i am so sore from shark fishing
yesterday
did you get into it yeah yeah very cool
it's acting kind of like a flounder a
little guy
another one came up off the bottom to
eat this thing
oh flat daddy thinks he's on the bottom
he ain't going nowhere
the gray fluke there you go another boy
there's like flounder number five here
and you know they say for
ninety percent of your fish are in ten
percent of the water yep they're not
good social distances
little guy a little guy a good release
these fish are going to be eating on the
paw look at you yeah
their little spunky flounder all right
there we go
all right guys well we caught the crap
out of those little flounders but we're
gonna try another spot and see if we
can't find some redfish and trail
[Music]
all right we just threw it for about
five minutes no real hints or sign of
action so we're gonna move and try
another spot
all right we've been popping these
little rattlers not much has happened so
we're going to try another spot
go try another spot
[Music]
nothing really bit so we're going to try
another spot
[Music]
well it's already about one o'clock and
we're calling it's one of those days
but we weren't skunked man we got into a
lot of flounder which was the one
species we
didn't think we were going to get into
so that just goes to show you
hi jacob
time to go out and kayak some baits the
waves look a little tamer today so
hopefully it won't be as much work
well i've got all three rods out and the
middle one got hit hard
and spooled like 30 40 yards of line and
they'll let let go
whoa that one's been going slack and
tight and slack and tight this one just
went really flat
oh he just hit it back
we might get a double that's terrifying
you might be on now
whoa did you see that oh he just freaked
out tommy
okay
there he goes all right tommy high five
oh my goodness terrible tommy boy
come on tommy
i finally reeled in the big blue rod and
they didn't just steal my bait
he bit through the wire we got to get up
at four in the morning for a fishing
charter tomorrow so i think we need to
call it and go to bed
hmm
all right guys it's 5 30 in the morning
we're here in hattaras and me and the
boys are about to get ready
to go out on a charter to go fish for
tuna and all sorts of things
we are tired but excited
all right
i think it's gonna be a beautiful day
man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right start off guys we're gonna be
trolling for tuna
and sailfish and marlin we've got a
bunch of these teasers and then we've
got some rigged up ballyhoo
and we're dragging this behind the boat
and seeing we can't get some tuna
or wahoo or marlin to come up and rise
to it
all right nathan's tackling the first
fish of the day
he's way back there
that's your first blackfin buddy
well it slowed down a little bit and the
boys have been taking a nap
getting up at 4 00 am is hard for a
little guy
hold off keep going what you got there
[Music]
something got away i just saw my man
here
smelling his bait he swears he can smell
the difference between a bait that's
been bit by an amberjack
versus a barracuda here
oh
there's ain't no blackfin tuna
oh that amberjack he can smell him yeah
he was on the set
that's my first amberjack right there
my first barracuda
[Music]
look at that
oh my goodness that was awesome
about the time that you can smell the
difference between a barracuda and
amberjack that's about the time you
start biting the nose off your bait fish
yeah top go for it i think you can get
him
yeah king mackerel just came flying out
of the water exploded like a northern
pike
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a third one oh man we got a
triple one to that rod
[Music]
[Music]
to win together nathan used his t-rex
drink
well it's been a fabulous day but the
rain's coming down we're gonna call it
and head on in we've got plenty of fish
okay boys look at me
[Music]
oh it's like a marble
[Music]
we made it home and it's already eight
o'clock and i
foolishly agreed to get up at 4am
tomorrow as well to go do this again i
am exhausted
well it's 5 30 in the morning and me and
tom got up
super early to go on a charter to
celebrate his birthday
we were gonna go fishing for 10-foot
sharks and marlin and all sorts of crazy
stuff
but it's six foot plus waves out there
and the captain's like yeah you don't
want an eight-year-old
out there so we're back at the condo and
we're gonna grab some flashlights and
we're gonna do some
pre-dawn beach combing all right you
ready yeah
those waves are nasty buddy look at that
pretty oh yeah that's a piece of a welt
that's what we want to find
big old jellyfish
[Music]
yeah a lot of big waves
yeah these are all hatched three uh
shark eggs
big ol it's a big old sand flea
well guys i don't know about you but i
am in the mood to eat some of that
fish and i'm going to start with the
tuna i think we should have some tuna
sashimi
tacos or pokey tacos first things first
we're gonna make a mango kiwi pineapple
pico de gallo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
blackfin tuna here
avocado or two wrinkles some
more cilantro
there little pokey tacos all right guys
who wants spoken tacos
[Music]
well we have been lounging relaxing and
eating
pretty much all day so far so uh we
finally got some energy up and
me and jake are gonna go to the fishing
pier
not much was going on at the pier so
we're gonna go and do some surf fishing
right here off the beach but
not with my big old shark stuff just uh
normal gear
there we go when everyone and their pet
dog is out fishing and catching nothing
use small hooks it's a number 12 right
there
also you don't need to cast that far
sometimes i caught this guy about 10
feet from the
from the shore okay both of you guys put
your hands on them one two three throw
them
my mom came by and asked me how you can
tell the difference between a fish bite
and the waves with the waves your rod
tip will slowly
load up and kind of go like this back up
with the fish bite it's all over
well becca are you having fun having a
great time but it's getting a little
cold should we pack it in well it's the
end of our last night here at the rental
house
and we are about three quarters of the
way through to blackfin
tuna this stuff is good but we're not
just packing up and leaving in the
morning
uh we're gonna do a live stream on our
youtube channel i'm gonna do a little
surf fishing and becca
michael flying in a biplane of all
things so
we're gonna see what tomorrow holds
checkout day and we're packing up and
getting the house all cleaned
i did about a one hour live stream went
pretty well caught a spot
in a black drum and a whiting
not bad for an hour fishing but it's uh
time for us to get going and go ride in
a biplane
well becca and nathan are going to be
going up in a biplane so i am going to
send becca with the camera here
there you go there's the batteries good
luck
nathan are you excited to go in this
yeah the pilot walk right up this shaded
area
we're excited
[Music]
this was super fun thanks so much you're
welcome come back and do it again
was that fun yeah i loved it i loved it
and it was scary did you have a good
time i
loved it it was so fun well hopefully
you guys enjoyed this little travel
adventure video if you guys want to see
more of these types of videos click
subscribe to the outdoor boys youtube
channel
and don't forget to check out our travel
and adventure playlist we do lots of
different types of videos
and we organize them by playlist and
don't forget to click subscribe and
we'll see you
next saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos
every saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching